vous savez je crois qu'on en est plus à
examiner l'aspect marketing des choses
et les formules qui sont employées il y
a une facilité employée depuis le début
du quinquennat et même et du quinquennat
précédent mêmes avant et cette facilité
qu'ils ont appelé quoi qu'il en coûte
aujourd'hui à le confine à la lâcheté il
faut savoir que quand on dit 5 % de
déficit on parle du PIB pas du budget ça
veut dire que l'année dernière le
dernier budget du quinquennat quand on
l'a voté pour cette année et bien ça
représentait 250 milliards d'euros
recettes 420 milliards en dépenses un
trou de 170 milliards d'euros dans le
budget de l'État et aujourd'hui les
Français et bien commencent à en payer
le prix énormément d'endettement c'est
énormément d'inflation et c'est aussi
demain et bien une charge de la dette
qui va devenir insoutenable alors cette
stratégie et cette tyres ça confine un
irresponsabilité et en plus elles sont
basées l'année prochaine et c'est un
gros reproche qu'on formule à ce qui
nous a été présenté sur des prévisions
de croissance qui sont bien plus
optimistes que ce que disent tous les
experts et notamment la banque la banque
de France donc aujourd'hui on peut
vraiment déjà s'inquiéter avant même pas
rentrer dans le fond des choses de la
manière très politique dont a été
construit ce budget et qui ne tient pas
compte des nécessités économiques de
redressement du